dinosaurs
are awesome we all know it
when we figured out these guys were a
thing we wanted more
more fossils more art more
well whatever this is so we went out and
found them
fast forward to today we're still
discovering
like never before
paleontology as a science started in the
1800s
back then we understood for the first
time
they were a unique and different group
of animals
fossil discoveries were happening long
before this distinction though
dinosaur bones were mistaken for
mythological creatures
thousands of years before science could
tell us what they really were
and for generations people connected
these fossils
to living creatures they already knew
until richard owen
frenemy of charles darwin concluded
these fossils were different
from any living creature on earth he
coined the term dinosaur the terrible
lizard new type of animal big step
forward
for the first 100 years we knew very
very little about dinosaur
we only knew 50 or 100 species or so on
discovery started slow but the public's
curiosity
was high so a view into this prehistoric
world
came from a different perspective
art
creativity brought dinosaurs to the
cultural forefront while these drawings
paintings and sculptures
were initially based on scientific
discoveries
let's just say that didn't last
our imaginations might have gotten a
head start but technology
it's catching up paleontology has been
undergoing this
massive revolution one of those
technologies
ct scanning giving paleontologists
a new look at dinosaurs you can look at
the brain size you can look at the
different parts of the brain
because basically the bones that
demarcate the brain cavity are
very good proxy for what the brain
actually looked like so there's a ton of
new morphological information that we
can get
through these high resolution imaging
techniques that are fairly new
this in-depth view has been a game
changer in the field
but one classical aspect of paleontology
has also experienced a renaissance
finding fossils in the u.s or in europe
that's where paleontology first grew as
a science
but other continents they have not been
explored
as much there are so many expeditions
being conducted right
now many many new dinosaur species are
coming from these places
example diego's team in patagonia
discovering the patago titan miora
one of the largest dinosaurs ever found
fossil discoveries in china are also
answering an age-old question
dinosaurs relationship to birds birds
are extremely rare
in the fossil record and this is for a
number of reasons
one is that birds are all pretty small
aerodynamics
limits body size so you can't get that
big
the other thing is that birds have
hollow bones they get crushed easily
they get destroyed and they just don't
survive
so all these fossil birds all come from
ancient lake deposits
the perfect environment to preserve
these very delicate fossils
birds evolving from dinosaurs is not a
new idea
but it's the access to these ancient
lake deposits
that's finally providing the necessary
evidence
the notion that birds are living
dinosaurs actually dates back to like
the second half
of the 19th century a guy named thomas
huxley
based on his observations he came up
with a hypothesis that
birds descended from small bipedal
dinosaurs
but other scientists opposed this idea
because they said well you know all
birds have a wishbone right
this is not known in any dinosaurs so
birds can't be living dinosaurs
next up john ostrom who analyzed
theropod dinosaurs
and also hypothesized that birds were
living dinosaurs
but again people kind of rejected this
hypothesis
at the time their new reason was
velociraptors that were supposed to be
closely related to birds
were much younger in the fossil record
than archaeopteryx the oldest bird
so they were like how could
archaeopteryx have descended from taxa
that don't appear in the fossil record
until like 70 million years later right
inconclusive evidence persisted until
well that's what brings us back to these
ancient lake deposits
so in 1996 you find the first feather
dinosaur in china
so then an enormous amount of field work
started to happen
and this produced these thousands of
specimens
paleontologists then discovered an area
where fossils predate archaeopteryx
and within this area they found small
feathered dinosaurs with bird-like
traits
including wings here and here making his
theory
much stronger also there was a little
trodanted dinosaur named meilong that
was discovered and it's really tiny it's
like this big
and it's preserved with its head
underneath its wings sleeping the same
way modern ducks do so that's behavioral
evidence
that birds are in fact living dinosaurs
today substantial evidence points to
birds evolving from dinosaurs
specifically theropods and showcases the
progression of paleontology
but the discoveries don't stop here
there are still
new things out there that once they are
discovered are going to shake up
everything we think we know new data
will cause us to adjust our existing
hypotheses so you just kind of have to
go with the flow of discoveries
[Music]
you